well Martin handled horf writes a blog
about the mobility of tomorrow and joins
us Martin why are you still writing
about technologies of tomorrow and not
the technologies of today why aren't
those technologies now because they are
so important for our society for our
economy for our future but but why isn't
it already happening
why haven't ecards caught on why aren't
people even more environmentally aware
then then what they become well we have
two major issues with electric vehicles
the first one is the lack of
availability of affordable cars with a
certain range and the second one is the
lack of infrastructure especially saw in
the report there especially charging
stations we have 6500 charging stations
in Germany but we have 120 to 150
million parking spots so there's really
well you see we need to invest a lot of
money billions billions and billions of
euro to get these infrastructure we need
when I see an example like in that
report of a PR guy giving our guys the
wrong cable to recharge their car I get
the idea that these guys aren't serious
about a mobility well German car
manufacturers have some problems with
electric vehicles because they wasted a
lot of money and internal combustion
engine especially in the diesel engine
and they have not really invested in
electric mobility so they will lose a
lot of money they are really panicking
about their investments and about the
stakeholder value so that could be maybe
the reason why they are done in West in
electric mobility and also not to be
able to bring really electric vehicles
to the market and it's not just about
big business it's also about politics
isn't it sure the German car
manufactures have a lot of influence on
politicians in Germany and when you're
thinking about some well the incentive
program of federal government you see
that they are not really interested in
making electric mobility a success we'll
get back to that in a moment Martin to
compared your
with some of the other key markets ECAR
markets but first of all let's take a
quick look at the numbers because as far
as what I've seen what the German
government of domestic e auto sector is
up against is quite a lot 45 million
cars with combustion engines are
currently out on Germany streets just a
small fraction of all German cars are
electric only about 25000 the federal
government's goal is a million a cars
registered in Germany by 2020 but
there's still a long way to go to reach
it the ratio around the world is about
the same globally there are just 1.3
million electric vehicles on the road
compared to 1 point two billion
conventional cars charging stations are
also desperately needed Germany had
installed a million of them by 2014 by
2020 that numbers supposed to go up to
12 point 7 million Germany is hoping
that a 4,000 euro incentive will inspire
more drivers to switch to electric
vehicles but in July of 2016
fewer than 1200 buyers claimed the cash
in the same month German drivers
registered over two hundred seventy
eight thousand conventional cars emo
bility is still lagging behind
okay we get the point Martin let's
compare Germany then to other auto
markets around the world what about Asia
how far is it getting with immobility
they are really great with electric
scooters and also electric buses and
also electric cars will come their first
in the next years do they have a much
bigger percent of of charging stations
for example in comparison to Germany the
deficit is so low
yes they have and Japan for Japan for
example there are more charging stations
and gas stations and you have to think
about the huge pollution in these cities
so the governments are really forcing
the people to buy electric vehicles and
not combustion engines what about the
United States and the likes of Tesla it
seems to be building and coming up with
huge plans and dreams that not on
anyone's radar here yeah they are
dreaming really huge but they are losing
also a lot of money so it's really bad
on the future who will be first in the
all t'market of the future it's a big
bet well what do you drive no car I
don't like her at all no just on your
bicycle like me and public transport
well done do you think we're gonna see
more of that sure definitely in the next
years and and more smart initiatives as
well smart cities with smart traffic
yeah we will see autonomous driving we
will see more on-demand mobility or
interconnection of different transport
modes and the soul just a question of
exactly when motherhood thank you very
much for coming in